the main asteroid belt between Mars and
Jupiter is home to millions of
meteoroids but how did these objects
form in the first place
astronomers have two ideas one thought
is that asteroid ancestors also known as
planetesimals became large through
gradual accretion grabbing more and more
material over time like a snowball
rolling down a hill the other idea is
that asteroids were made by a
gravitational collapse that the space
dusts that makes up the asteroid smash
together almost instantaneously because
eons of collisions have broken apart
these original asteroids scientists
aren't sure which one of these series is
true but they've made a big leap toward
proving the latter similar asteroids
have sorted into groups called families
researchers selected a family of
asteroids known for their low
reflectivity in an area of the belt
where there's a large amount of brighter
asteroids each of these dark asteroids
were in a slightly different orbit but
when mapped out the asteroids were in a
v-shaped formation
unlike the brighter asteroids nearby
this pattern was more spread out not
only does this mean that more collisions
happen but that radiation pressure from
sunlight shifted their orbits gradually
over time the extent of the spread means
that these dark asteroids have been
around longer than middle lighter
neighbors the researcher suggests the
original dark planetesimals were
probably formed four billion years ago
making this one of the oldest asteroid
families in the main belt because the
researchers determined that the original
planetesimals were no smaller than 35
kilometers across
they say this is compelling evidence for
gravitational collapse because it's
close to the size average needed for the
hypothesis to work but for now there's
still a lot of work to be done before we
know the true origin of our companions
in the belt
[Music]
[Music]